il était resté muet lors du premier
procès c'est un père de famille offensif
qui se tourne vers les médias désormais
avec de nouveaux arguments qui selon lui
fragilisent l'accusation
effectivement et qu'il y a beaucoup de
doute d'un cohérence qui permettent de
dire que l'enquête n'a pas été au niveau
d'une enquête portant sur un fait aussi
grave que la mort d'une personne
qu'on reste comment investigal la
mortuse et péda a distingué 14 points
précisément il joue la carte déjà connue
de l'absence de trace de preuves
formelles et charges sans retenue la
justice française
la première c'est qu'il n'existe pas de
témoin qui ont vu de leurs yeux Nicolas
faire ce qu'on l'accuse d'avoir fait
comment Narumi a-t-elle été transportée
depuis sa chambre jusque vers la forêt
si elle était vivante elle l'a fait à
pied
le procureur dit qu'elle est partie dans
le véhicule de Nicolas
de la voiture qui s'en va
ce véhicule la police l'a analysait à
plusieurs reprises de A à Z ils l'ont
trouvé aucune trace je dis bien aucune
trace d'ADN qui permettrait de prouver
que Narumi était morte dans ce véhicule
je lui demande alors ce qui a pu se
passer cette nuit là
je ne le sais pas
c'est tout l'intérêt de l'enquête c'est
ils ont utilisé tous les moyens de la
terre
des hélicoptères pour survoler la forêt
des hommes des chiens de recherche des
drones
ils n'ont rien trouvé rien absolument
rien
où est une alors si elle est vivante
dans le savais même nous ne le savons
pas non le savais MOS quand Nicolas
s'est séparé d'elle elle était vivante
que s'est-il passé après nous ne le
savons pas
cette enquête n'a pas été faite pour
retrouver Narumi elle a été menée pour
trouver un coupable et ça c'est grave on
coule pas
si le procès reprend Umberto Zepeda sera
entendu reste une question les jurés
seront-ils sensibles à ces nouveaux
arguments